[Música]
vamos a isso vamos a isso é vocês são
muito simpáticos eu estava vindo aqui
para portugal e no avião
o atendente me disse 'você por esse um
artista português quem antónio variações
eu fui atrás de antónio variações na
internet descobri que ele era muito
animado e eu não tenho nada de animação
dele a maior animação da minha vida é
passar um sábado à noite com as duas
meninas
anita e aurora das minhas duas filhas a
aurora frozen e ela me pede para me
vestir de princesa elza eu digo não
posso investir de princesa filha e ela
disse então você não me ama papai e eu
digo amo então se teste e eu me visto eu
tenho essa barba ea minha filha acredita
que eu sou a princesa elza
eu não aguento mais brincar na neve e de
vez em quando eu bebo 3 uísques e eu e
visto sozinho de princesa em casa eu não
sei o que está acontecendo comigo
eu gosto de estar perto das minhas
filhas elas falam coisas interessantes
as crianças acreditam na gente acredita
num mundo encantado eu perguntei para
minha filha menor que você vai querer
ser quando crescer ela me disse um
unicórnio
eu não sei como vai ser o vestibular
dessa menina a os pais me contam
histórias maravilhosas um pai estava
colocando a minha calça na filha a filha
levantou o pé
o pai percebeu que estava trocada e
disse ao outro pé e então a fifa
levantou outro pé eo pai percebeu que
ele estava errado era o primeiro pé
então eu disse é um outro pé ea criança
disse não tem outro pé pai ea menina que
foi voar de avião pela primeira vez
entrou dentro do avião estava empolgado
e excitado e o pai do lado vamos lá para
voar de avião ea filha feliz e o avião
começa a subir e ela pai em que momento
vamos começar a encolher porque ela viu
os aviões subindo no aeroporto
maravilhosos crianças são maravilhosas
quem tem filho que levanta a mão eles
nos ensinam a ser melhor todos os dias
são pequenos anjos anjos que chegaram à
nossa vida nos transformaram num se nos
inspiram a ser melhor no mundo na vida
existem duas coisas as coisas que você
controla e as coisas que você não
controla pelas coisas que você controla
você tenta ser melhor se você controla
todos os dias você pode ser melhor você
controla a sua profissão talvez seu
casamento você pode ser um melhor marido
você pode ser o melhor pai mas ele tem
coisas que a gente não controla e por
isso a gente agradecido por isso nós
somos gratos pela anip pela aurora terem
chegado na minha vida me transformado e
transformado num homem melhor no pai
melhor me transformado numa pessoa
melhor
a sorte tem dessas coisas
existe um ditado irlandês que diz que é
melhor ter sorte do que ser rico não
acredito nisso
eu prefiro confiar na sorte eu falei uma
vez com um amigo meu boa sorte ele me
disse
boa sorte é para incompetentes
eu faço a minha sorte eu falei carro
eu não
tem coisas que eu não controlo pelas
coisas que eu não controlo eu espero que
seja tudo
esses dias eu fui fazer uma palestra
tinha que andar 200 quilômetros aluguei
um carro no meio do caminho de um
pedágio eu não costumo andar com
dinheiro eu sempre só com o cartão de
crédito
no meio do caminho tem um pedágio no
brasil não se aceita dinheiro se aceita
apenas o cartão eu virei para atendente
disse
tem alguma coisa que possa fazer era 2
euros 10 reais e ela não você tem que
voltar a 25 quilômetros sacar dinheiro
no caixa eletrônico
andar mais 25 quilômetros e me entregar
10 reais 2 euros
eu falei você não pode me ajudar eu todo
dia tem que ser melhor com as pessoas eu
me esforço para ser um herói
eu me esforço para ser um anjo para as
pessoas eu carrego a mala de velhinhas
no aeroporto
eu ajudo as pessoas eu o que me pede às
vezes não têm dinheiro para comprar o
seu livro anjos eu envio do meu dinheiro
eu pago em virgem veio aqui pra portugal
professores que pedem livros porque não
conseguem comprar quem estiver
assistindo na internet isso não é para
todas as pessoas que o envio mas eu
tento ser bom eu tenho o seu anjo que as
minhas filhas acreditam que eu sou e ela
disse não tenho que fazer senhor volte
25 quilômetros saque no cartão no cartão
de crédito você pega dois euros volta 25
quilômetros e me pague mas eu tinha que
fazer a volta em que eu passei pelo
pedágio fiz a volta não volta tão
indignado que eu abri meu coração com a
outra atendente disse que você vê
eu vou ter que andar 25 quilômetros a
cada dois euros voltava em cinco meses
para pagar a sua colega do outro lado eu
disse não eu vou pagar pra você deixa
comigo eu estou tentando ser um anjo na
vida das pessoas
julie brown e falei eu também
obrigado e ela me deu 10 reais
então eu fiz a falta e parei na outra
atendente disse à ae o que eu consegui
existem anjos para aquilo que você não
controla aquilo que você controla sejam
um anjo seja um anjo
a gente olha para o mundo ea falta de
confiança nos faz achar que não existem
pessoas boas no mundo se você não
encontra pessoas boas seja uma seja uma
eu tiver sorte da minha mãe cuida de mim
o meu pai biológico abandono ela grávida
eu tive a sorte da minha mãe ficar no
brasil são 20 milhões de mães solteiras
20 milhões de mulheres que cuidam da sua
família que cuidam dos seus filhos
sozinhas e por isso elas não têm orgulho
nós tem culpa no coração eu pergunto a
vocês uma mãe solteira uma mãe solo
deveria ter culpa a culpa de quem
abandona não de quem fica
a culpa é de quem foge e não de quem ama
em outras fotos da minha mãe a lemos me
mandou existir algumas fotos quando ela
quando eu era muito pequeno e quando ela
era muito jovem e me teve a renúcia
angeles cuidou de mim e me deu não só a
atenção e amor mas ela me deu a vida
dela
ela me deu juventude dela ela me deu
sonhos profissionais dela porque ela
tinha que cuidar de mim não podia
aceitar todas as promoções
ela me deu seus sonhos amorosos as
pessoas que ela queria se relacionar e
eventualmente não queriam uma mulher que
já tivesse um filho
a minha mãe me deu a vida dela também
não era uma pessoa fácil quando estava
na escola vários dos meus amigos tirar
belgium voz notas boas e ganhavam
presentes e minha mãe sempre dizia não
fez mais que a obrigação
essa é a frase da minha mãe
os meus colegas todos ganhavam
videogames quando passavam de ano ea
minha mãe dizer não fez mais que a
obrigação
eu tirava 10 e mostrava para ela não fez
mais que a obrigação
obrigado mãe e fui crescendo e fiquei
mais ou menos famoso no brasil e minha
mãe ficou muito orgulhosa ela fala meu
nome alto nos lugares públicos agora a
gente está num restaurante ela fala
márcio e anjos como quem não quer nada
[Risadas]
ela tem orgulho espero que alguém 2010
uma foto pegar um autógrafo
esses dias eu estava no programa que
passa de madrugada um talk show papo
madrugada no pedro bial do meu lado
estava o cauã reymond vocês conhecem o
reino um ator muito bonito muito famoso
a minha mãe mandou umas ap
você está mais linda do que o cauã
quase que eu respondi não mãe eu pareço
mais o antónio variações
é uma coisa minha mãe me ensinou a minha
mãe me disse você não é seu pai
biológico
você não precisa repetir todos os erros
dele você pode ser melhor
tem coisas na vida que você controla as
coisas que você controla você se esforça
para ser melhor
um dia você vai ter uma família e um dia
você vai ser pai de um dia eu fui e essa
aqui é anita e aurora ea minha esposa
ana e elas me ensinaram a ser pai porque
eu não tive a inspiração eu não tive um
pai
elas me ensinaram a ser pai quando
estava ausente elas que puxaram dizia
'pai você precisa trabalhar - pai às
vezes pra você olhar pra gente a gente
precisa ficar atrás do seu telemóvel
elas começaram a lhe falar coisa um dia
e ela eu e anita fazendo um bolo eu
falei ainda vão tirar uma foto e votar
no instagram e ela não pai
vamos tirar - fotos e viver mais a vida
real
minha filha uma criança e todos os dias
todos os dias elas me ensinou a ser
melhor
quem tem filho que levanta a mão vocês
já ouviram a palavra de novo já ouviram
falar uma palavra só que nunca para você
joga eles pra cima tirando joga mil
verde não o tirou do jogo não é que leu
um livro novo 20 verde novo quem não tem
filho levanta a mão não tem filho
aproveitem a vida fiz um seriado do
netflix namora em depois que nasce um
filho eles querem dormir na cama junto
com o casal
eu não sei como a gente faz dois filhos
eu não sei como a gente consegue impedir
que tem três
quando as meninas chegam elas me ensinam
todos os dias a ser um pouquinho melhor
todos os dias a ser um pouco mais atento
todos os dias a entender que de novo é
eu te amo pai fica aqui pai de novo pai
fica do meu lado eu gosto de você
o seu cheiro eu gosto da sua conversa
pai você me ensina
e elas venceram também elas me ensinam
todos os dias
o problema das famílias e das relações
hoje em dia não é um problema da
tecnologia da falta de confiança ou da
falta de segurança nas cidades é um
problema da falta de conexão é um
problema de falta de conexão cada um
vivendo a sua vida cada um no seu
celular
terceirizar a educação dos seus filhos
para o youtube para o netflix para a
galinha pintadinha não pode ser um
caminho
nós temos filhos a inspirar uma nova
geração
nós temos filhos para nos inspirar ser
melhores pais deixar um mundo melhor
para melhor pra eles e deixar filhos
melhores para o mundo lá em casa a gente
começou a perceber que existe um
problema com tecnologia então a gente
tirou por três meses a internet não é de
casa
eu sei que vocês estão pensando teremos
ricci três meses sem internet ouvindo
reg fazendo pulseiras de couro foi
incrível foi incrível a gente começou a
usar uma técnica muito antiga não seja
ouviram falar uma técnica que os antigos
usavam chama conversar você já ouviu
falar nisso
depois procure no google tem tem uns
vídeos tutoriais no youtube você abre a
boca é bom eu o doi outra pessoa ou
ouvir e aí a vez dela falar você tem que
prestar atenção e você conecta e
conversa a minha filha nesses três meses
a menor prendeu a lei escrever sozinha a
conexão que existe uma família que está
sem tecnologias em e mail para responder
sem grupos de what's up é incrível ea
gente começou a fazer nossos nossos
próprios jogos de tabuleiro que são
muito mais baratos muito mais divertidos
elas adoram aurora sempre pede para
botar um unicórnio que acontece quando
caiu o único ganho o jogo vai para o
mundo de arco-íris eu tá bom filha ea
gente faz os nossos labirintos de fita
crepe é extremamente barato elas adoram
brincar disso a minha esposa odeia
a minha esposa chega do trabalho e dizer
eu não vou ficar me arrastando no
labirinto eu vou destruir e eu digo para
as minhas filhas chegou o monstro chegou
o monstro
eu tive sorte de ter uma mãe que cuidou
de mim eu tenho a sorte incontrolável de
ter duas meninas que me ensinam todos os
dias tenho uma esposa que me entende e
me ajuda a ser melhor todos os dias
algumas pessoas chamam isso de deus essa
sorte
essa sorte que nos invade quando a gente
não consegue controlar as coisas
essa coisa boa de encontrar anges
encontrar pessoas boas no dia a dia
sempre que eu ia levar a minha filha
para a escola eu chegava lá e as minhas
filhas sempre elogiam você é linda você
é forte o córrego dos sacolinhas ela
como você forte pai eu sou mesmo
eu cheguei na escola da minha filha
tinha uma menina na frente da escola
chamada gabriela e ela olhou pra mim e
falou como você é feio e roupa alguma
coisa está errada que meu pai é bem mais
bonita
parabéns seu parecer muito bonito mesmo
deixei a minha filha lá ele foi embora
cheguei lá no outro dia para levar minha
filha quem estava lá na frente da escola
gabriela esse é o seu carro carro do meu
pai é bem mais bonito que o seu parabéns
gabriela mas se é bullying você não pode
ficar falando isso comigo por favor me
respeite está aqui minha filha um abraço
boa aula foi embora subir no outro dia
quem estava lá cabrinha como você é
fracote meu pai carrega numa mão só
eu fiquei eu comecei a ficar com medo de
levar minha própria filha na escola
porque não queria encontrar gabriela
mas eu tinha mais medo da minha esposa
levar minha filha encontrar o pai de
gabriela porque aí acabava o meu
casamento
esse cara incrível maravilhoso que era o
pai de gabriela passar alguns meses
estou brincando com minha filha na
frente da escola chega um homem pra
pegar gabriela
eu pensei estão seqüestrando o gabriel
não pode ser o pai de gabriela e era era
o pai de gabriel
ele não era george clooney e ele não era
o homem mais lindo do mundo
mas ele pegou a gabriel no colo fisk na
casa dela e gorgouff leandro cheira e
gabriel os olhos da gabriela brilhando
ele ouviu que a gabriela tinha pra falar
porque ele tem muita coisa pra falar a
gente nunca ouvi o que ele tem para
falar ele ouviu e colocou gabriel no
carro velho dele e botou sinto gabrielli
voltou às coisas e fechou a porta e
foram embora os dois
a gabriela eo herói da gabriel
o homem mais lindo mais forte bem
sucedido do mundo seja o herói que o seu
filho acredita que você seja o herói que
o seu filho espera que você seja seja o
herói das outras pessoas e se você não
tem filhos seja o herói que sua mãe
espera que você seja muito obrigado
e com lago brigar
se cada um obrigado obrigado obrigado